China has reported its highest number of
new coronavirus cases in almost six
weeks authorities say a hundred and
eight people were infected over the past
day mostly travelers returning from
abroad while that number is low it's
adding to concerns of a possible second
wave of cases Sara Clark joins us now
live from Hong Kong so quite a rise in
the number of cases does this start to
draw some proof to the fears of well a
second wave well certainly this is the
concern that China has we've looking at
the second wave of infection
particularly where this area is or the
cluster of the 108 cases it's in the
northeast of China in a province called
Heilongjiang and in most of these cases
came from that particular city and as a
result and we've had tough new measures
put in place in the capital of that
particular province known as Harbin a
stay at home measures people being told
to stay indoors as well as the city that
borders Russia now all of these travels
almost these travelers in his latest
cluster of the infections we're coming
back over the border from Russia back
into mainland China and as a result all
gatherings have been banned at train
services have been stopped and the
health checks will now be mandatory for
all people coming in from Russia now
this is a monetary coronavirus testing
as well as a 28-day quarantine as a
result now as you mentioned 180 cases
that's up from 99 but this is where the
new battleground is or certainly the
northeast of China is where the
government authorities will be targeting
and we have been seeing a downward trend
of the corona virus infections in China
and some would suggest it's in a
recovery mode but they're being
questions about the calculations and the
accuracy as well as the accounting
methods are being used on the figures
coming out of China the World Health
Organization applauded China's efforts
to detect the corona virus outbreak
early but other countries like UK and
the US have questioned the figures
Donald Trump
questioned whether or not the debt tally
was actually on the light side now
looking at the the current figures at
the moment the death tally is 3343 and
the cases of the corona virus infection
in China is eighty-three thousand one
hundred and thirty-four cases so that's
certainly low when you compare it to the
likes of the United States and Europe
now
issue of the treatment of Africans in
China causing some new diplomatic sparks
to fly right now we saw a number of
reports on social media over the weekend
from members of the African community
living in the city of Guangzhou this is
in the south of China and their claims
were of mistreatment are being evicted
from their homes also being denied
access to restaurants and hotels we had
some students saying they were being
denied food and now living on the
streets and that their suggestion is
there now being targeted and their
community of suspicion and they're being
accused of spreading the virus in
Guangzhou in our background to this the
African community in Guangzhou came
under scrutiny after we had there were
claims that a number of them ignored
some quarantine restrictions in that
setting on Thursday last week we had 114
new cases confirmed of the corona virus
in Guangzhou and 16 were Africans and a
group of them were Nigerians are linked
to a particular restaurant now several
African nations have now responded to
these claims of mistreatment there
that's like some garnet and IG react
Kenya and Zimbabwe and they've done a
demand and China act on these claims now
on Monday we've had a response from
China they've said they've denied the
mistreatment they said basic there's
been no discrimination against their
African brothers and they said they have
a zero tolerance for racial
discrimination against the African
community in that city now this
statement was made by the Ministry of
Foreign Affairs it was also backed up by
the mayor of Guangzhou on Monday all
right Sarah Clark there thanks so much